least favorite guest on the chat
show you gotta be hon you got to be
honest you gotta be honest well I
actually I can because I
uh I actually I gave this up and and and
this is someone from a long time ago but
it was when I was first starting the
show and we had I mean this amazing
singer actress Eartha kit was on the
show and a lot of people know her from
the 1960s Batman she played Catwoman a
little bit but she was on the show show
and she was very tough to talk to and I
was brand new and so I put most of it on
myself but I'd say things like oh you
dated James Dean you know back in 1954
and she'd say well so what what you why
you asking me and also I would I that's
not even a question it's just a
statement yeah it's true that's I guess
that's
on as I
said I was brand new
Ed
now I think this is my least
[Applause]
favorite we have a new winner I did I
did put it more on me but I will tell
you this there was a type I'm not going
to name a name because that feels like
I'm being a dick but there was a type of
person which is someone who had not um
there's a kind of person who uh has not
had a lot of life experience they made
it they're young they're 19 they're 20
they're they're on they're an actor and
they they seem entitled and they'd come
out and they wouldn't have any real life
experience like I can talk to you and
you can talk to me about being young and
not having money and and and taking the
tube around and trying to make it work
and you're connected to reality and
sometimes you're talking to these people
that uh were literally like raised in a
hydroponic environment to be on
television or you know and on a WB show
and they just had nothing to say and
they're we're narrowing it down getting
there okay keep going so they come out
with their eye
patch and they're now we know um but but
no and you'd say uh so tell me when you
were young well when I was you know
remembered when I when I turned 16 and
my agency got me a Porsche and I said I
wanted silver and they brought blue who
drives a blue
Porsche and you'd feel hate just come
out of the crowd so who who would be
because you would have regular guests
who who'd be the one that you know you
knew the booking was coming to be like I
love those you know oh my God I mean
there's so many but but the one that you
were like super super pumped for every
time they came nor McDonald uh was
meaningful to me cuz that so so so so
and and will frell people that would
bring they would bring something to the
table I mean will frell came out once
and he he had prepared it but he came
out and he had a bird on his
shoulder and you know how will can just
commit to something with those
eyes and right up front he said no
questions about the
bird and so I commit to just it's this
giant white
cocko and he you know we'd be talking
for a little bit and I'd be go like yeah
and the bird would start to move around
on his shoulder and be easy Co is there
a problem there a problem there and he'd
be like we're not talking about the
bird it was just fantastic but I mean so
I loved it when someone would bring
something that would turn the whole
thing upside down on its head you know
have I answered enough of your
questions hey I have a new album coming
out I'm really excited
about I'm sorry it's called uh it's
called Autumn
[Laughter]
variations